[Music]
exactly I think what let's do it
this matches no matter what dress you
would have I totally agree and if you
want mine mics wrapped up in a napkin
over behind me no come on
what's it doing wrapped up in a napkin
because I don't have a clutch explain
yeah tell me about this tell me about
this Johnny wear would be jealous
wouldn't he
I think so you know we went to Jeremy
Scotts studio and he's just incredible
so he pulled out a bunch of options but
I saw this and I said you know what it's
crazy it's different and I think that
pretty much sums me up in two words
crazy and different and you're proud of
it absolutely any more pressure being on
the Oscar red carpet than being on the
ice right back up like Jennifer Lawrence
and and you say who are you excited to
see definitely Jennifer Lawrence and we
would have a figure skaters if we didn't
say Margot Robbie and Danny what did you
think of how would you critique Margot
Robbie's ice skating ability oh really
good I was really impressed
you know I'm not really brave outside of
bigger skating so for her to come out
like that and I said that's what I'm so
embarrassed that I said I'm proud of her
but I really am and when I see her
giggle you're gonna say you're a good
ice skater I think I think I may have
found my all-time favorite ice skater
enough they didn't let your personality
shine through enough in at the game
moment in time give us this fashion spin
please the triple axel on the red carpet
there's a red carpet triple F there you
go oh nice ice down there on the red
carpet you did that so smoothly is
Dancing with the Stars next I see we're
kind of waiting right now we still have
the world championships coming up so
we're just you know taking everything in
we're here tonight we're having a great
time and baby you never know what both
I'm here doing it both good wanna I mean
why not like competition I think I would
take him on pretty well
[Music]